I think United States of America and Mr
President for the new defense package
for Ukraine a very powerful package
thank you so much and it has exactly
what our soldiers need
well that was zolensky today big meeting
on the hill and at the White House but
the truth is political support for
continued Appropriations for Ukraine is
declining especially among Republicans
but Democrat Pat Ryan from Kentucky is
he from New York or Kentucky I thought
it was from Kentucky but tried to blame
it on extremists saying that the Very
extreme right has hijacked the
Republican party and lost this
bipartisan consensus we had that we are
for democracy and for freedom
but our next guest he actually supports
helping Ukraine and will explain what's
really happening here Congressman Mike
Waltz great to have you with us you sit
on the armed services and Foreign
Affairs committee congressman now if
there's no doubt about it uh in both
parties support is declining among the
people who actually pay the bills right
what are you saying
well look number one Biden has
screwed this up we deterrence failed on
the front end then he refused to give
them what they needed to actually win I
mean drug his feet everything from
Patriots to tanks to planes and then now
he's basically backed us into a
stalemate and won't come to Congress or
the American people with a strategy for
how long are we going to be in this
what's in our interest how are we going
to get there number one number two Laura
you know he wants me to go to my
constituency American people and say
keep digging deeper in your pockets
we're not going to tell you how long
we're not going to tell you how much or
the strategies you get there but won't
ask the Europeans to dig deeper into
theirs and I'll just leave you with this
stat nine out of the 31 NATO countries
have lived up to their two percent
commitment Germany just backed away from
theirs despite their promises last week
so they're promising a lot they're
talking big but what they're actually
delivering is a fraction of the military
aid of the United States and when we've
got our border out of control every time
an American goes to the gas pump
inflation's out of control but yet to
say more more and more and put the
burden Biden wants to put the burden on
the American people not the Europeans
not the International Community and I'm
at the point where unless we can get a
strategy and the Europeans to step up I
can't continue uh to support unlimited
Aid going forward the Hera blank checks
nobody wants anyone to roll over Europe
but one would obviously that's not what
anyone wants however
one would think if this were truly an
existential threat to the West
that the West in the closest proximity
to Russia and Ukraine would in fact be
ponying up the cash and they're not
doing it and yet our borders out of
control we just did the most disturbing
segment about Biden waving in 500 000
work permits for Venezuelans more more
to come and Americans are like what
about us it's not that we don't support
democracy of course you support
democracy but this is not 1988 we don't
have the cash we're 34 trillion dollars
in debt and we have a lot of Republicans
on the hill and I'm not trying to name
names here but who are just like well
Ukraine Ukraine what are you going to do
about Ukraine I'm like what are you
going to do about Arizona Texas Florida
and every other state that's having
trouble look I've said repeatedly
stopping Putin cold was in our interest
they're doing the fighting and dying
asking for the for the beans and the
bullets but you know what who's going to
provide them who should provide them
we're out of money Poland for example
has an economy a fourth the size of
France yet is providing four times as
much France Germany Italy those big
economies aren't stepping up and in fact
they're they're backing away and I mean
they're not sending weapons I mean
Poland yeah they'll say they're sending
their promise cash over a lot of years
but what they actually send and they're
not sending weapons and it's weapons
it's going to stop this war not all of
this other hot air but I'm from the
Europeans one of those things that I
have trouble with maybe you can help me
with this is that we are policy as a
government seems to be continuing to
engage with China in fact throwing
ourselves at the feet of China
I think trying to make China richer and
more prosperous bring China along maybe
they're going to like us more and yet
China is helping Russia so as long as
we're you know completely
embarrassing ourselves uh with China how
are we going to the American people to
help Ukraine when we're helping China
the largest solar panel Factory in the
world is in western China on slave labor
being powered by coal-fired power plants
on Russian coal so this this administ
registration's climate Obsession that is
selling out the country and putting us
right in the hands of of the Chinese how
how damaging is it to conservatism today
uh and I would say it's much more of an
America First conservatism you know 84
percent of all the people are supporting
either Trump or DeSantis or Vivek
ramaswamy that's about 84 of the
electorate everyone else has a little
support but not much that's really where
the party is and given that what about
Senate leadership how do you see it over
in the house do you feel like we have
strong leadership in the Senate that's
really carrying the torch for the
policies that the voters care about I
think what the American people want to
see right now from Senate leadership is
getting our border under control and
fighting uh to do that and that's
exactly what we're going to send from
the house over to the Senate with these
funding packages but Laura can I just
say one other thing to say you know for
the Democrats for Biden to say if you
have questions about funding you the
Ukraine war if you want to see a
strategy if you want to know how long
this is going to go if you want to see
real burden sharing that you then don't
support democracy as an insult to them
it's an assault to the American people
it's an insult to me well it's these
people are for packing the court and for
flooding the country with by the end of
the bite Administration it'll probably
be like 12 million people that's that's
if you want to lecture about abandoning
allies let's go right back to the
Afghanistan withdrawal and the message
that that's into the world that
basically green lighted uh Putin to to
go in but Congressman do you agree then
with McConnell that Biden has been slow
on funding Ukraine because
I mean it sounds like that's what you
were saying earlier that we needed to
give them if we only gave them no it's
not more money let's get them what they
need to win
right up front and into this thing
rather than drag things out I mean one
thing we want to clarify is it's not
bags of cash it's the military hardware
give them the tanks planes they need up
front win it but now because he's slow
roll rolled all of this it's going to
get this drug out he's backing us into
an endless war and then he wants us to
go to the American people and say keep
digging deeper in your politics
Americans are going to end this war and
it's going to be ended like Iraq was
ended and Afghan I mean it is going to
be ended one way I mean people are not
going to go on for these forever Wars
anymore what's the path what's the path
to a peaceful resolution summer
offensive spring offensive now it's the
fall offensive maybe it'll be the winner
offensive I mean I I just think this is
a Fool's errand to think that Americans
are going to keep saying yes to this as
much as we want Ukraine to succeed and
of course we do um of course it's so
good to see you thank you for holding
their feet to the fire and come back
soon hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else